hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zurück
zu einer weiteren folge zusammen mit
hallo hey hey das letzte mal hat mega
viel spaß gemacht und deswegen indem wir
einfach noch mal drei runden mit auf-
beziehungsweise zwei runden wenn ich
jetzt direkt schaffe zwei runden zu
gewinnen zeit nur zwei runden oder wenn
man das schafft uns fans halt drei genau
schauen wir einfach mal aber ich denke
mal du wirst direkt schon nach der
ersten zwei runden vernichtet werden
wobei ich immer noch gott das ist aber
so richtig als sie an den radfahrern
damit komme da nicht mehr durch guckt
das ist richtig ein sehr oft lücken
lassen dass man die chance hat irgendwie
dadurch da irgendwie durchzukommen was
momentan einfach nur cool wenn ich das
spielfeld dann so ausdehnen würde weißt
du gott ich hoffe es doch geschafft er
20 0 in den beiden spielen insgesamt
waren 30 oder witz dann werde ich etwas
weiß ich dann mache und wie du dir auch
immer vor dem tor ab anfang der rote
trauben szenarios denkt so also wie
solarien es wird schwierig 0 aus
da habe ich gehört ob man komme hatte
winston danke spiel habe ich ja gar
nicht mitbekommen
jetzt nicht okay auch wenn das heute 20
2 ausgehen würde es wäre ein traum
jetzt aber jetzt wieder ein punkt mache
achtung können wir können dir alles
klappt ich hatte ja ich verschwende
durch frage mich schon warum ist überall
blau auf einmal kann man eigentlich auch
durch den gegner durch fahren also durch
die gegnerischen strich oder kannst
das kann man nicht das kannst du nur
wenn du dieses ding hast dass du keine
schlange hinter dir hast weißt du was
schönes altem einfach alles weg
guckt das ist wenn du das hier hast mach
mal das hier ja ja sagt münchen köpfchen
laser luca ich bitte dich vorleser mich
abgeben habe ich eigentlich nur wegen
unserer mir so ausgedacht aber das logo
oder das design das war so knapp da
braucht es lohmer 50 ich weiß nicht
philipp wahrscheinlich vergesse ich habe
ich versuch's reinzubringen welches
gleich direkt
jetzt mache ich genau das was du immer
bei mir machst com herr kollege
ja da kann es sein dass du immer diese
situation gewinnst ja keine ahnung
anscheinend gerade und ist auch nie
waren ihr könnt sie den komplett loch
komplett alles passen damit wir sehen
was hier so los ist so mehr den rechten
dingen zugehen
für den 11
heute sind wegen seiner
charakteristischen jetzt in salz
gestaltete komplettieren dachte doch so
witzig ich war wie verdacht boden
krümmte stufen bis mind technologies ag
christoph hat ja 64 cook und ich wette
der gleich wieder so eine brenzliche
situation ist dann wieder gamma de
willst darfst wir überall durchlaufen
was alles was geht
hallo ich bin ich keine walter h
gewinnt natürlich gewinn immer ich bin
ja noch einmal des spiels
sensibilisieren ich dass du gewinnst
aber vor dass auch die zweite runde
glaub ich gewonnen oder oder habe ich
jedoch drücken was weiter haben die
zweite hast du wir wollen die erste habe
ich dann doch wer ist total gegen fette
das ist total traurig der beleidigt man
die fetten hier gehöre ich einmal dick
oder gegen eine wand kommen will dass
die ganzen fed gewandt laufbahn
vorbereiten keine gerüchte titel dies
ist meine ich mein ich quatsch
wir gegen dünne aber ich führe ich führe
acht zu fünf mal die berufswahl
aber ich hole auch ich habe den kleinen
auf ich habe einfach gar kein nicht
schlecht dass ich der bild schlagzeile
kraft hat den kleinsten der gar kein
konkreter outet sich
er hat kein youtube mit soundso viele
abonnenten ich weiß jetzt gar nicht
glaube ich finde du hast youtuber oder
penis immer richtig geil
das ist jetzt meine tolle taktik mit den
kurven lenken direkt gerade meine lieben
freunde direkt gewonnen kiel los gehts
komme möchte bereit
ich bin so was allein entscheiden ich
sag doch 10.0 mache ich hier heute mal
wenn ich ein 10 0 machen was bekomme ich
so etwas gemacht hast du bild von mir
natürlich extra cookies wirklichkeit 10
aber die heute extra verlieren
11 diese musik ist wie irgendwie aus
welchem spiel kommt das bekannt vor
pokémon kampfhelikopter quelle hilfe
kommt neuer gott warum wollte so schnell
aber ich weiß nicht
man bekommt dann so viele effekte ich
dachte die als scheinbar aufs spielfeld
wie man dass ein einschlag von jaja die
entscheidung auf dem spielfeld aber ich
hab so ein ding eingesammelt für dich
ach so ja verstehe ja das war ich habe
auch die blaue linie geachtet gruppe
erfährt aber gewahrt okay weil irgend zu
denken jetzt jetzt jetzt willst du auch
wieder direkt dran weil wir nicht mehr
portal crash fatal wenn wir echt mal
direkt frontal ineinander fahren und da
ja schon
ich fand hier oben rechts unten links
sind okay und jetzt fahren aufeinander
zu es war klar es war einfach klar es
war einfach klar es war einfach klar
dann sind das gewisser ich sein wo
damals auch mal noch mal nach dem typen
der im rückstand stehen
ich bin ich aber normal weiter hier
hierbei muss natürlich noch ein bisschen
hier eine scharfe kurve geschafft hätte
vor geringer nicht in der kurve
beschleunigen auch nicht bremsen weil es
dann zum showdown kommen könnte wir
haben dann hat man aquaplaning ist auch
meine güte war machte ich immer auf blau
gut alle gefahren jetzt gibt's mehr
verwandeln
denn links ist alles frei bekommen was
macht er wehrte sich selber ja ich
wünsche dir auf 72 ich glaube es wird
sehr sehr eindeutig jetzt heute das bild
von mir bekommen können so viel glück
muss man haben
ich strenge mich jetzt mal wieder an
hier komm ich hab den kleinen vorsprung
genauso okay jetzt stehen sie mal wieder
ein okay gut
auch das ist doch nicht wie ich diese
spiele gewinnen das noch oder nicht
schreibt sind die kommentare jetzt video
gibt es noch 10 minuten hier geschieht
dann wird klar ja gut aber es ist jetzt
so wie im letzten video wo ich dann die
erste runde gewonnen habe und du die
zweite jetzt drehen wir den spieß mal
oben und du gewinnst du erst die zweite
eigentlich habe ich jetzt schon 2 0
gewonnen und du kannst gar nicht mehr
gewinnen
aber egal ich bin jetzt einfach noch mal
runter denn echt fahl wir noch eine
runde machen kann man noch 100 wieder
warum wir haben doch in dem video heute
erst eine runde gespielt nähe 29
doch ich schwöre auf mein leben zwei
ehrlich ja stecher beide gewonnen
alter geschlecht war ich denn hier
gerade kommt muss man reinkommen ja ok
eine runde geht noch natürlich gehe ich
gelernt hast aber es passiert einfach
gar nichts was so erwartet
die lobbys weg dadurch jedoch nicht nur
eine runde aber wir werden dann
eventuell irgendwann die tage noch mal
das aufnehmen weil das macht echt spaß
finde ich wie findet auch das jeden fall
das recht egal ich dachte früher immer
so man bekommt davon kopfschmerzen und
das macht überhaupt keinen bock
inwieweit man da nur wenig ist eine
linie fährt aber es macht wirklich
behindert die spieler basis ist legal
also ich denke wenn die tage einfach
noch mal irgendwann das spielen und ihr
könnt ihr einfach mal eine bewertung
lassen wenn ihr das wollt dass wir das
noch mehr hochladen
denn sonst würde ich sagen wir sehen uns
dann irgendwann wieder